[Music]
you
[Applause]
please be seated
executive vice president Tolstoy faculty
colleagues alumni masters candidates and
their families and friends good
afternoon and welcome to convocation for
masters candidates in the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences at Columbia
University I thank all of you for coming
to celebrate the many accomplishments of
our masters candidates we honor today a
magnificent group that on commencement
is coming Wednesday will join the ranks
of our close to 40,000 alumni and who
will embark on professional and academic
careers around the world in the great
tradition of Columbia University our
candidates will always remember this day
even with the passing of the years they
will manage to recall that their
Columbia masters convocation took place
on the very day in which the faith of
dine Aerys Targaryen
[Music]
[Applause]
the fate of the diner's Ogron and the
Iron Throne were fulfilled but of course
I digress equally important we also
honor today the families and friends of
our candidates who have endeared with
them the rigors of their academic
pursuit thank you for being so
supportive and understanding I if you
let me finish I would ask all masters
candidates to rise and applaud those
friends and family members who have
helped them to be here today
[Applause]
the student remarks to the graduating
class will be offered by Miss Diane Z
originally from Shanghai
Deon's Lee joined the tenth oral history
Master of Arts cohort oh is it gonna be
a long afternoon were she as a graduate
of Sarah Lawrence College where she
concentrated in history and public
policy her interest in oral history
stems from her curiosity about her
family's experience during the Cultural
Revolution Dionne considered herself a
lifetime Aurel considers herself a
lifetime oral historian she currently
works at a nonprofit media organization
applying her skills of oral history and
academic research to focus on programs
related to media branding and licensing
Miss G
oh that's my husband and I know that
sounds like ten but I only have one
thank you ding along so executive vice
president Tolstoy faculty and staff
family friends and a big shout to my
family friends over there I cannot do
there without you and of course and of
course the MA class up to the nineteen
my mom still doesn't understand what I
was studying at Columbia and she is not
alone
about ninety nine percent of people I
have talked to have no idea of what our
history is I guess because of my accent
of pronouncing it about after my
attempts to explain seventy five percent
I would never say oh that's a little
different from what I thought of art
history I don't blame them compared to
the historical traditional historical
research our history is a fairly young
as less not well known field which is a
study of history by interviewing people
who have personal knowledge of the past
in 1948 historian and journalist Ellen
Evans created the first institution
based or history program in the world
right here at Columbia since then the
Columbia University Center for our
history research has become the home of
over 20,000 hours of recorded and
transcribed interviews today Columbia
the only University in the United States
that offers graduate program that solely
focuses on our history and that's why I
came to Columbia I remember the day I
told my mom that I wanted to study oral
history for graduate school she has
lived in China her whole life in oral
history is even less well known in my
own motherland so she was very confused
but she wanted to be supportive
so she immediate reply go for it
I'm sure you'd be good at it then after
a few hours she asked me so sweetie what
was the thing you say you want to study
and you know I love you but are you sure
that you can landing a job after
graduation yes the fear of an unforeseen
future was real but still I only applied
for one graduate program I got in and I
became a member of the tenth cohort of
our history Master of Arts throughout a
program we learned a lot about a
methodology and practice of our history
but if you want me to sum it up into one
sentence I would say I learned how to
listen not hearing but lessening truly
nestling at first it was difficult for
me to differentiate listening and
hearing a more demanding we only use one
word to express both here and lesson
that was teen for me listen was here
here was listen just like team was team
use of one's ears to get to receive
information however I was told multiple
times throughout the program for in our
historian hearing your interviewees
stories would not enough you have to be
alert you have to give consideration and
thoughtful attention you have to listen
so I tried my best to listen the first
oral history project I conducted at
Columbia was a project I work with ever
crown Wikimedia in for 2017 focusing on
the marginalized ethnic and linguistic
communities within New York City area
during the semester I listened to a
young anti casts out asian asian the
lead activists talking about story of
being discriminated and bullied in
school because of her darker skin when
she was 3 I listened to an NYU professor
in Haitian ink wasted telling a story of
being approached by his
Ranger who wanted to correct her poor
French when she was speaking her mother
tongue Haitian Creole I listen to a
musician telling the story of starting
his music entrepreneurship in Bushwick
Brooklyn and teaching Garifuna music to
the children from his community I listen
to her stories of passion of pain of
childhood of vulnerabilities of pride of
discrimination of womanhood of love
during my journey in lessening to Murray
way me and James I found myself
documenting ordinary people fighting to
preserve their heritage from an
individual and intimate approach I found
myself facing my ignorance of other
cultures and languages I found myself
standing with them reviewing the
civilizations that surveys from personal
narratives then I realized the ability
to listen should not merely be an our
historians job no man is an island we
owe the obligations to listen to other
people's stories because every personal
voice mummering
aloud matters in our history we believe
what is personal is political
what is individual is public my cultural
anthropology professor once told me that
in today's media a terrorist attack in a
non-western country is not even as
important as which team won a football
game on a Friday night the TV will only
give 30 seconds to those non-western
tragedy and tragedies or they only
report on those countries the neck
lating of some voices encourages
Foster's ignorance and discrimination
toward certain communities in today's
media society and political contact and
we as a promising future of the world
need to change that if you ask me where
to start a journey of listening I would
say start listen to other people
struggles in life I lost two loved ones
during my time at Columbia my good
friend nan Tyler offspring cancer in
fall 2017 then I lost my grandmother who
raised me since I was a baby when I was
working on my thesis I was devastated
gradually falling apart I lost track of
how many nights I couldn't fall asleep
staring at the ceiling like Erica meek
and like it'll give me an answer I lost
track of how many mornings I could not
wake up hiding myself from the sunlight
that I could escape from everything
there were many moments I tell myself
would I ever be able to finish the
program and prove out with all the pain
and the grief however someone at
Columbia heard my creaking for help no
they did not just hear it they listened
to it my program directors Mary Marshall
Clarke a mr. Chesky and my professor
Jerry albertalli were there paying
attention to my straw ghost
offering understanding and help and
waiting for me to save myself from
darkness with patience I remember the
emails that Amy sent me I remember the
quietness of Mary Marshall's office
where she spent hours listening to my
pain in convincing me that about
vulnerabilities could be converted into
my strength
eventually I finished in our history
article documenting my personal account
of love and death and my graduation
thesis I landed in a job I truly believe
in bringing the ideas worth spreading to
local communities around the globe in
other words I could not be here today
without there listening to my struggles
at the first place so my fellow of to
the knighting graduates don't become the
generation that is afraid of mindful
conversations go listen as family as
partners and as friends listening to
others were not
callate grant answers to their questions
but your listening will make someone
realize their valued sometimes ones lost
so just need to hurt by one listener go
lesson as family members as members of
communities and concerned citizens
listen to people from different culture
political and social economic contacts
listen to their perspectives of the
world you thought you were familiar with
become a humble student again in every
day's listening then utilize the
resources and knowledge we harvested at
Columbia spread the words view the
bridges and wait for the changes you
want to see in the world
my mom visited me from China a few
months ago she asked me to take her to
my favorite place on campus I took her
to the wall rolling the names of more
than a hundred 51 countries and learner
hall every day it reminds me why I chose
Columbia at the first place full stories
of different cultures of different
voices thank you and congratulations to
my fellow cast off to the knighting it's
exciting day let's celebrate and enjoy
and start listening to each other from
today thank you
thank you Miss Jean today's keynote
address will be offered by Professor
Tian Liang professor of statistics and
associate director for education in the
data science Institute Tian Jiang
obtained her PhD from Columbia in 2002
she develops novel methods for exploring
and understanding patterns in complex
data from different application domains
such as biology psychology and
climatology her current project projects
are in the field of statistical machine
learning spatial temporal modeling and
social network analysis
professor Jiang's research has been
recognized by the 2008 outstanding
statistical application award from the
American Statistical Association the
Mitchell prize from ISPA
and a Google research grant she became a
fellow of the American Statistical
Association in 2014 professor Jiang was
the recipient of the 2017 Colombia's
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching in 2019 she became the section
chair for the a si section on
statistical learning and data science
professor Jiang
being alone so exactly vice president
history-- my distinguished colleagues on
our families and front most importantly
the ma graduates of 2019 thanks for the
invitation to speak at such an important
occasion I would like to offer my most
sincere congratulations to all of the
today's graduates on your academic
achievement I know firsthand how hard
you have worked as some of you bluntly
stated so and the teaching evaluations
of my course apply data science
shortly after accepted as invitations to
speak at today's ceremony I decided to
do some research about graduation
speeches as this is my first time doing
this I thought I should collect some
data as a professor of statistics would
approach any life situation with a
deadline but that was weeks away I
procrastinated despite the fact that the
one thing and emphasized the most in my
own teaching is start early as the
deadline to close I became a bit anxious
with the help of Google and one of the
talented students from the amazing
statistic program here and young who is
graduating today I squid 108
commencement speeches from the internet
true to my inner data scientist fathoms
through an artificial intelligence
program and here is a speech that it
generated
oh so how I wish this was true I was
just joking I so wish that that kind of
AI already existed I really did though
scraped the 108 speeches and then
applied my non artificial intelligence
to analyze them as data I found some
quite interesting trends for example it
was reassuring for me to see that more
than 30% of the speakers explicitly or
implicitly acknowledged that they didn't
know what to say I struggle to think
about what perspective I would share
with you the soon-to-be graduates of our
master's programs about 90% of the
speeches in my dataset share the stories
of one's past on the other hand the
topic with key words work and life
appears less frequently work and life
this is a topic that follows us
everywhere there are times when you give
it our full attention should I take this
job even though it will require me to
travel and be away from my family
weeks at the time but more often more
and more often than not it's a silent
dilemma
should I sorry
hiding behind our daily decisions should
I attend my music the should I attend my
child's music assembly at school or
spend the time adding a new example in
my lecture note before my afternoon
class at graduation as you are all set
to pursue your career aspiration some of
you may also feel anxious about how to
maintain a good work-life balance today
I will share two stories about work and
life the first story is my growing up
story as a professor I never wanted to
be a professor
most kids even some grown-ups don't know
what professors do I did
both my parents were professors and are
now retired
as early as I can remember I knew they
were important research your papers and
books they revealed grant proposals and
promotion cases attended those fun
conferences and mostly dry but sometimes
eventful meetings they tell interesting
courses and mentor students in their
very different styles my parents worked
at out hours all the time as a fourth
grader I learned an important life
lesson that is still helpful today when
you have a pressing deadline and have
still got a lot to do don't stay back
don't stayed up late go to bed early and
get up before 5:00 a.m. to work more
productively join the 5 a.m. Club as
they were called at that today a life
hack I learned at age of 10 and mastered
before junior high to me my parents were
working all the time their work followed
them home to the extent that than 10
years old knew what they were talking on
I didn't know the phrase work-life
balance at that time but if I did I
would have said my parent needed more
more of it according to Wikipedia in
physics balance is a desirable point
between two or more opposing forces to
the 10 years of me work and life were
like two solid weights on opposing side
of a scale my parents obviously had a
much heavier weight on one side than
other I decided that when I grew up I
would not become a professor I had this
thought even after I started graduate
school it was a summer internship that
changed my mind
at that time I was working during the
day while making progress on my
dissertation in the evening this was
very exhausting don't try it at home
shortly after I started doing the summer
internship I found myself missing the
academic lifestyle where I didn't have
to stop at a certain time if I was
deeply
immersed in solving a problem to this
day I don't actually mind the fact that
academic research follows you around I
might be waiting in line for popcorn at
a movie theater and have a ha moment
taking a break can turn out to be quite
productive so I decided to give academia
a try as a 25 years old I had a rather
undesired rather unpopular desires
actually wanted to become my parents
when people here work like balance they
often think of compartmentalized perhaps
even rigid daily schedule as it turns
out though there are many forms of
balance math math it was speaking if you
bring the two opposing ways infinitely
close and fuse them together it's always
balanced just kidding just like many
mathematical theorems this is true but
limited in practical applications in
biology balance or homeostasis is a
state of steady internal physical and
chemical conditions maintained by
leading systems such as body temperature
and fluid balance being capped within
certain prison limits maintaining a
work-life balance is like choosing what
where are spring summer day like today
wear layers so that you can adjust to
your own comfort level at a moment's
notice my favourite notion of balance
now surprisingly comes from statistics
as that addition can have her head in
the oven and her feet in the freezer and
she will say that on average she feels
balanced no one can tell you what
balance will work for you it is working
making every effort to find a work-life
balance that works for you and the
people who are important to you even
though my parents worked a lot they were
and still are always there for me most
of the time I really love what I do as a
professor
my second story is about one
life-changing moment when I wasn't happy
about how things were going it happened
a few years ago when I was teaching my
linear regression class I remember it
was utter clarity as I said it was a
life-changing moment I was lecturing
harmattan room 502 standing in front of
the classroom I could see the beautiful
campus through the oversized windows it
was early in the morning I came directly
at fit after finishing my hectic morning
routine sending my kids to their schools
the lecture was about one of the
relatively dry topics algebra heavy as I
recall as I observed my student looking
bored I feel like I was dying inside at
that moment I thought to myself this is
now the kind of lecture that is worthy
of my mourning battles with kids so that
I can make it on time after that class I
racked my brain to come up with an
approach that would be more exciting for
my students and at the same time
wouldn't require me to set up to the wee
hours of the morning writing lectures I
really enjoy mentoring students in
research projects I figured so I created
a new course apply data science which
allows me to do exactly that and just
that every semester students work on
five projects that cover a broad
spectrum of data science skills all of
these projects are designed to be
realistically unstructured and
open-ended like project in the real
world I received inspiration to creating
this project from all kinds of sources
one of the earliest project was born
from a trending tweet Labradoodle or
fried chicken in this project student
create AI algorithms locating this time
to distinguish between photographs of
labradoodles and photographs of fried
chicken one team found a single feature
that can account for about 25% over the
prediction rate it boils down to the
fact that a piece of perfectly fried
chicken
it's a shade more golden than a
labradoodle puppy real-word insights
confirmed by data over the past three
years we have had a lot of funny ideas
so - oh the ad has alarmed here today
thank you for making my work a fun part
of my life
[Applause]
finding your own work-life balance will
not be straightforward or easy it is an
open-ended research project which if
done well earns you a lot of extra
credit the challenging here lies in the
fact that work has many quantifiable
benchmarks well life just doesn't it is
very tempting to focus on the more
measurable goals but they shouldn't be
the only things that matter I watch some
of this things thesis competition videos
on the YouTube channel of GSEs
this videos allow me to learn allow me
to learn about the research project done
by the ma students outside my own
department in your project here at
Columbia you have created a mazing
dashboard to show gentrification in your
New York City you have dug deep into the
roots of injustice in our society and
you have advocated the preservation of
endangered species you have embraced
challenge you're having with challenges
and overcome your fear of the unknown so
here is your next research project but
one in which you are the only one
evaluating the results find a work/life
balance for yourself it may be the
physics definition the biology
definition the statistics one was
somewhere in between as we say at each
project release in apply data science
your project starts now here are the
only here are the only two rules you
number one when you are tired or not
feeling well don't work you're number
two have fun all of us at Columbia look
forward to hearing about your research
results maybe one day we can feed all
our work like balance tiles into an AI
program and it will speed back the idea
balance I wish you the I wish you the
best with your future work and the next
stage of your life congratulations again
thank you
Thank You professor Chang we now arrive
at the central point of the ceremony the
presentation of the Masters candidates
we ask you to come forth as we call your
name in recognition of your individual
accomplishments Daris Burch and
Priscilla Yuen officers of academic and
student affairs in the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences will read the names
of the ma candidates as they cross the
stage
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
african-american studies Robin price
Pierre receiving the degree Master of
Arts in American Studies Brennan
McDaniel Daniel Flores Rochin horsey
knee Laila halal Anna approch cow
Emily tang grace Shen
Benjamin Cole
Shabnam Sholay Banerjee McFarland Jose
Martinez Tim barnacle receiving the
degree Master of Arts and anthropology
Joseph recupera Timothy McGee
Joo Chun song Jeremy Bradford yo Yong
Chun di wall receiving the degree Master
of Arts in art history and archaeology
Amanda Mauro jungmo Marwan che Chen Yu
Shu
odda Burke tie Sydney Wilhelmina Alison
Chatfield Richardson Bartolome glama
Mattel schmeyer receiving the degree
Master of Arts in biomedical informatics
leisure Rennes Joan won yow none each of
in each Anant Jeremy Kai way Lou
receiving the degree Master of Arts and
biological sciences Alisa our check our
chest she G same FF receiving the degree
Master of Arts and biotechnology Rachel
coiny Ritu Sarkar receiving the degree
Master of Arts and biological sciences
Natalia an M yak receiving the degree
Master of Arts and biotechnology
Jennifer who lead Yong Chun you kun li
xiufeng
yo ho Kylie Andrew Brant Alexandra
Olynyk
Stephanie Hodapp Libby Ward Jacob Hess
Samuel Chu receiving the degree Master
of Arts in East Asia regional studies
chuan Ming chuan to resit ding ling ling
schwinn Loy Kelvin in Connie
Natasha sim Lee Heung Hmong la Kwang
Alex Smith receiving the degree Master
of Arts and classical studies
Vanessa Stovall faith McFadden nathan
sparks league washi receiving the degree
Master of Arts and climate in society
Jang Shi XI Leo Yoochun Lu Yi she went
Xu Wei Lin Kristen Hogg
Sarah Smith Florida Sarah Maria Dom brav
[Music]
Arlie titler Phillip Harrison Jean Yin
hi
Wang Chi done
Kolya Guan wrong
Noel koenraad Alva Bennett
yes mean Alexandra cordial Nabila Islam
Michael Owen
Stephanie stats Elizabeth Perry Peter
Francis stunning receiving the degree
Master of Arts and earth and
environmental sciences
Andy Wang Bali white receiving the
degree Master of Arts and East Asian
languages and cultures Jeong Ning li
Xiao yi
xu yun when Alexander Michael Chen
Kristen Shriner Melissa Lee Hong Lee
Thomas flippin Lian Jie TT
Tang Xuan Lucy 100 Juliana Tonchi Li
Ling side chin young receiving the
degree Master of Arts in ecology
evolution and environmental biology
every LD as Sophia right l je shown
Alice woo Jacqueline berry
Emily Jager barrel Khan Montana re
Nicholas Luca telly receiving the degree
Master of Arts in economics Schrom on
gosh Samia Jane Juhi Sharma Pratyush to
worry
Simran Ahuja dirting Wong Wong loo lo
Leoben tan Gwen Lee Noah
Oliver Patrick boat aundrea Queenie
Rocco Giovanni Oberon Marcella cartlidge
Jean foo 1 June June 1 momming when Leo
chinnu
Josie Han unioning Jungmann gray Willian
mean John Besh ow
Advaita Aaron Madhuri Prabhakar Shiva
cusine Sarah Margolis Kayla Brotherton
oolagah semi fiqar Wong chiffon Leo ET
Lin Zi Jing Leo mingyang talmadge wise
penny who ching pun Matthew Schwartz non
dursa loss jacob grossfeld alexandria
grazie OSI soon you Chun Fey Tenenbaum
so Shu Noah receiving the Master of Arts
in global thought Surya Surya Bonetti
Chloe Tim said Maria Xhosa fina Vargas
Llosa
[Music]
melanie burger Elena ghoulish cow amber
who Vermont
Emily FIDIC Emma harvest Joe Murphy
[Music]
Raphael carpet Yan Ella follow Mayer
Beatrice go
Ilyas shirali a beam of Sitharaman
Michelle Lee Sarah Shaw cuz are sure
mama Dolph
Claudia Herbert colfer Malaika Robinson
[Music]
gaia song Tim sadoc Tiffany batiste
Helen and Nasim Bria Harden Boyer Kunal
Shankar receiving the degree Master of
Arts and history and literature Erin
Mayo Tyler Allen Susie Chavez receiving
a degree Master of Arts in international
and world history Anthony Howell
receiving the degree Master of Arts and
Human Rights studies watching Ruth
Nadine Elka Bruce Lee
Victoria Miller Trisha Maharaja
[Applause]
Adam vice sundean added or Lily Gill
Dakota Porter Anoosh bugged us ariane
victoria pitt lick my d hazara Choksi
imam muhammad Claire Arrington Lucia
vidal de la pena Tania sitar Kenny new
yen Genevieve Xing Ito damn bean Elena
lalaki Laura Guerra Gina Kim Siri
McFarland Benjamin Isaac Joseph mincer
Dean Angela Ford NC receiving the degree
Master of Arts in Islamic studies
Jamal Rahab Justin William Houston
Wiggins receiving the degree Master of
Arts in Japanese pedagogy Naito Chikako
Yumiko Geller Khanna Pearce receiving in
the degree in Latin America and the
Caribbean regional studies Randall
blades
Jeremy Curran
Mariana Garcia Camilla month later Terra
Yanez receiving a degree master of arts
and mathematics of Finance her CG Jung
through way Matthew dollar no Philip W
Connelly Fung eachin Wang Shi BAE Leo
BAE BAE Jong Yoon shoo us do hushing
Rajat Gupta stiffened Iran Pyrrha Tien
Raul voluntary on door
Esther love Nova wanting lease EE
Tong how Jia Bao Ying Ning Zhang Yao
Jerry Chiu receiving the degree Master
of Arts and mathematics
neo see Jia receiving the degree master
of arts and mathematics of finance
serene Kim
Qiu Yu Xin shooting phone Wang mang Fei
li Shang
Jeffrey Lee Yun REE young Tim Nye hurt
John Wall journey whew yo Xin Yi Xuan
Tong wait see shoo frankly to you Jia
Qian Yin Chun Fang yeah yes shouts Ian
jong-hong Tao receiving the degree
Master of Arts in mathematics suit yeah
receiving the degree master of arts and
mathematics of Finance
ding Yan Chun Jen Lin Shu Ren you Yankee
son Jeong Jeong Jean son yi wang shi
jing Sokka
Luo chi waan Jan Ling Wong Jing her you
one younger receiving the degree Master
of Arts and statistics a la me Alice
Huang Lian young Tenten one you Joon
young young
seeing the Anton Lucas Honda Castro
young fan Wang Geeta
jeonggi Shing mu tiempo Jing Yi nan Yu
wen ting you Cheng Hao Wang Qing Han
receiving the degree Master of Arts and
Medieval and Renaissance Studies Valerie
Wilson
Emily Gebhardt receiving the degree
Master of Arts in Middle Eastern South
Asian and African Studies
Andrew Austin Vita Hassan yamani Elly
Elizabeth Kempton Mina Joffrey receiving
the degree Master of Arts in Middle East
Studies maneuver Gulch a receiving the
degree Master of Arts in Middle Eastern
South Asian and African Studies
Nora Borromean receiving the degree
Master of Arts in art history and
archaeology
Alexandra Adams
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
art history and archeology Meghan
Collins receiving the degree Master of
Arts in art history and archaeology
Ashley Theo sahrin receiving the degree
Master of Arts in art history and
archaeology Ivana dizdar Alessandra
Gomez miss Syrian Sally Eve's huge pujan
Gombe she Clair seeing Lee
song yiqiang anise receiving the degree
Master of Arts in modern European
studies Tara Eric Niemi Anna coolster
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
European history politics and society
Gabrielle Higgins
Eduardo Vicari honor gun arson Joseph
puke nur receiving the degree Master of
Arts in music leme Cheung receiving the
degree Master of Arts in museum
anthropology chan soo yeah receiving the
degree Master of Arts Museum
anthropology Victoria Lee Antonio
Maggie Tomaszewski
Molly McGee R receiving the degree
Master of Arts in nutritional and
metabolic biology mashing on receiving
the degree Master of Arts in oral
history Brad Bailey derald be Cuba jr.
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
oral history keine patel at the N ELISA
Funderburk Eunice Kim Holly Werner
Thomas nari Abdul Shafi and Cardenas
Rebecca Louise mcgillvary Caroline
confer Valerie fence
carlins yeah wong kim hee-jung g
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
physics
Joshua Swan Dora Becky receiving the
degree Master of Arts and philosophical
foundations of physics Lipa long Sakshi
de l'anne sure Iran Joseph flap
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
philosophy quand a bean mean on Han TN
tree Kim Jung Oh receiving the degree
Master of Arts in political science
Ilyana sans Kelly
barold Conor Johnson Changi loon
Josiah pona Durai Christopher Paul
Masson Oh Bianca la depot David Sutton
Alejandro Armas Darrell lung Ileana jo
Jung Mong Han Magdalene TA Oh Ryan Lee
[Music]
Jasmine Jacob AJ colio Kasim Shafi
Fernando Nunez Chen Guangcheng waiting
ye Latifah Assad palak Shah
Jenny Gunderson receiving the degree
Master of Arts in quantitative methods
in the social sciences Michael McCarthy
Jo Chu Tian Ashley who Litwin Jessica
Iseman hailey Aronson Evan Smith Darrell
long Sean qu on hee Jun seong-ung
sunset on easel Lee Lee Eun Jung Marita
Nichols right Chen hua ha
Angie Jung studio Poddar
Kendall lo Maleeha tarik Dali satin
matte learner
Andres Castro araujo Shailene Reynolds
Kyle Davis Fong songy alicent yang Xiao
Qing Yao Fanny Fang Fang one thing lead
us on
Xu Bing trip epi John session Jang
whooshing receiving the degree Master of
Arts and statistics monk jr. John yeehaw
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
quantitative methods in the social
sciences wah-fung combing your young
Xiao Xuan yung Jing Yi fan je Phil Wong
Yuen qu you
Chen Jia Yi Katrina Jung receiving the
degree Master of Arts in religion Robert
Lindsey Saladin Mac suit Steven
novakovic receiving the degree Master of
Arts in Russia Eurasia and East European
regional studies Christian ammos
ekaterina malikova
jo Gamzee
receiving the degree Master of Arts in
Russia Eurasia and East European
regional studies Jennifer Ginsberg Tina
Tina barriga
goalie at Lake Nova receiving the degree
Master of Arts in Slavic languages
Claudia Kelly receiving the degree
Master of Arts in sociology Anna darling
[Music]
Lois son Lamar Courtney LaVon Castleman
Rachel chiotti Monica Claudius Kaitlin
Cunningham Keon Hannah love Claudia
Hernandez
ISA sari Camus Kim Jae won
Andrea Avila Ali back kiss eBay
Addison Malone Tessa
Constantin Eva Jahan Christine sim Saudi
Arabia sylia Lao Lee open Fei Liu ji yi
Anna demenna
Gonzales pong Vidya Katara's an apology
receiving the degree Master of Arts and
statistics Wan lutea John Rae Xu Zhu
Ying fawning
ting Shri in huangshan jeans the Jia Li
you Han li Xiao ting
su you Gia
Leo you Chi Yong Shi hoo chef a Samuel
Collins attache cigar
RP Tasha
Michael Otomo Oh Joshy Gwangju TIA
Adam Constantine Patrick hefferman Jenna
Weinstein Lu Xiu en
Oded Lowenstein
Matthew Saturday don't ya chi-chan see
our loot Yahweh Wang Chung you eating 1
through 10 ones yeah
one man's read soon cursed rare Yong
Chun Tong you jihadi king way Georgie
John Cheng Kuo Shiraz Yan lineage in
what's away quato
Jiang Shi Leo tae Liang Chow chung-yong
you Jia Qian wait sure why tian-chu
Eamon yanti Amin
jojoba Lisa you're an hanbok
who Ming chuan ung turn patent along
what oh ye shoot the yan Jeong Jeong
ChiHong Wang Xiao ya
Leo Channing woody
Shannon young wenching her Xiao Yu
jeong-ho you ty o 1 john waggi go han li
pay lean in each AR one Sun Joon run how
young li Hao so young
yup young here on shoe Poong her home
team Jang Yi Xiao chance at home Zhang
Xuan here you how dong GU Chi pong he
Fung how ray
Ranjit zhao jiamin
Kalia huangshan shouting long searching
challenging one here way sympathy when
LAN wait out here Johnny being the one
on Yi Li or a shirker judge you Han sway
one team gijn you function way Wang
Shang Lee Quran Legion shoot y'all a tae
yang Wei Yi ran by Rossi John pay Lou
Wong foo yung
Jiang Yu Qi Han Xin Zhao Shang Guan
Chansey
Deepika Namboothiri parrot Jones she
Anka Giovanni Castellanos Leo when ye
Sun shouty
tunxi two three tae Gong SIL young one
Korean Leo xiaochun Louie son Ming Wei
Lee Eun fan Chani Anton drew home boy
Jung Jun CAI woo you fan
sure eating in chan-sung
mahi Joon harsh on whole when Han Chang
monkey jimmying home payphone
Isabel beers choi jung-woo
[Applause]
and now my parting remarks to the
graduating class during your stay in
this institution we have endeavored to
train you how to think write and speak
like a member of an academic field as a
participant in an intellectual community
defined by the morals and conventions of
your discipline leaving in the process
little time or room for much else indeed
looking back at the foundational myth of
the modern University one can defect
readily a desire to place an institution
in a location of exception with respect
to the social as an enterprise that
derives its force and reason for being a
reason for being from its insularity
from its distance from societal concerns
this is part and parcel of the
apprenticeship model of graduate
education and explains to a large degree
the sense of loneliness that we have all
felt at one time or another while in
graduate school as if we all had to
recreate for ourselves and within
ourselves the principles tenets of our
chosen discipline and thus engage in a
project of intellectual self fashioning
that necessarily had to keep the world
at bay given the efforts you have
expended in achieving this goal you
would be justified in thinking that the
triumph that you have celebrated today
surely should be enough and yet the
Spanish philosopher Jose Ortega y Gasset
wrote in his meditations on Don Quixote
in 1914 just as the world was about to
embark in a characterless cataclysmic
war an aphorism that comes to mind to
describe what I'm hoping to convey to
you as you leave this institution yo soy
yo a missile constantia is Enola Salwa
ya know me salut
yo which can be loosely translated as
I am myself and my circumstance and if I
do not redeem it
I cannot redeem myself there has never
been a more connected more trans
national infrastructure linking us
instantaneously to other individuals
than the one that has been built by the
technological scaffolding of our digital
world but paradoxically we have also
never been farther away than we are now
from experiencing a sense of the Commons
farther from the belief that we have
some responsibility to our brethren and
from the principle that what is best is
what is good for the largest number of
people arguments that rely on the
assumption of the common good as a given
appear to have lost their power of
persuasion because what was once a given
can no longer be assumed to have
collective purchase and assent it has
taken us a long time to arrive at the
melancholy realization that just because
we can communicate with countless
unknown individuals were not by that
very fact creating a community the
university may have been created to keep
the world at bay outside its walls but
we should not allow that methodological
foundation to determine our relationship
with our surroundings the very distilled
concentration the monomaniacal attention
to your intellectual projects that has
allowed you to be where you are today is
a decided strength but it can also lead
imperceptibly to what we draw from the
world that is not that different and its
effects from outright neglect struggling
against the insular experience in its in
its effects and it's the internal
experience in which you have to immerse
yourself to be successful in graduate
school will perhaps be the most taxing
the most demanding task you will
undertake in the net
few chapters of your life as that you
begin today nonetheless everything that
you have learned that Columbia will only
acquire its full significance when
you're able to articulate its meaning
for the comments in spite of the
requisite headlong plunge into our
disciplinary Millia that has
characterized your time as a graduate
student you we must never lose sight of
the larger social context that will end
our work with ultimate significance we
are as a society at peril of losing that
sense of responsibility toward a common
good without which our work will be
diminished but more important without
which no understanding or application of
justice may sustain itself your studies
have endowed you with powerful
analytical tools and equally effective
powers of persuasion and you should use
them to protect the health of the social
compact to strengthen the resilience of
our common bonds strive to be happy as
an individual but always keep in mind
Ortegas admonition that if you do not
also endeavour to redeem your
circumstance your own personal
fulfillment will be in jeopardy never
lose sight of the fact that many many
persons even absolute strangers have
contributed sometimes invisibly to this
very personal success of yours that we
celebrate today and that the best way to
acknowledge that death is through your
renewed commitment to the essential
business of being human among and
alongside other human beings we arrived
then at the end of this magnificent
ceremony go forth to be our
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
make us and your relatives and friends
prouder still about you than we are
today
will the candidates please stand so we
may give them a final round of applause
you are invited to a champagne reception
immediately following this ceremony at
Ansel Plaza under the tent
I asked friends and families to wait to
exit until after the faculty and the
candidates have assented the low library
steps
[Music]
you